uh wonderful to be here 28 we've done 28
episodes this is the 28th which is
amazing
i can't believe it
so great so wonderful
yeah i don't know how many people saw
our first episode our first very first
episode
well this is fun this is kind of a full
circle thing i don't know if you
remember i did a monologue on the first
episode about an amazing experience i
had an enrique
okay yeah
doesn't always get applause at an
enrique iglesias concert this is real
i'm not [ __ ] around with my joy quota
here's a recap of what happened
i bought tickets to see enrique iglesias
uh yeah yeah it was a good i should say
i bought ticket to see
enrique iglesias no one wanted to go
with me
i loved it i did this four times i went
like this i went
yeah
that's right
the only downside to that wonderful
magical night was that at one point
during the show enrique needed a
volunteer so he could serenade the
person and uh weirdly he didn't he
didn't pick me
but yeah i know
that's the response i wanted from
everyone
i'll take it from one man in the second
row
but here's the good news enrique saw the
monologue and then he tweeted it he
tweeted at me he tweeted me me pete
holmes and then yeah no i tweeted back
i tweeted back i hit it right back at
him ad enrique and then it went back and
we would tweet tweety talks we had some
tweety talks and then when i thought it
couldn't even get any better than that
he sent me this
hey pete i'm sorry i couldn't be there
with you i'm here miami recording my new
album but i wanted to tell you that i
love the new show i love that monologue
you did and um next time you come to one
of my shows if you wear lipstick i'm
picking you
ready
that's
amazing it's the circle
it's the circle of life
if i've learned one thing from doing the
show as opposed to doing life stand up i
can't sing so it's the circle of life
and it moves us all
you can quote shakespeare or poetry for
free but the second you're like
30 grand